nous sommes en banlieue de moscou dans
une des dizaines de polycliniques
n'arrête pas de recevoir depuis deux
jours des citoyens en quête d'un minimum
de sérénité
je suis pas seulement ici pour me
protéger mais je le fais pour les autres
aussi dit vladimir en nous montrant le
texto qu'il a reçue du gouvernement
vendredi
le message confirme qu'il est une
personne à risque puisqu'il travaille
dans un hôpital il a pris rendez-vous
sans hésiter et le voilà quelques
minutes d'être vacciné contre la copie
chaque personne qui se présente pour la
vaccination doit prévoir environ 20
minutes d'abord une consultation
médicale
après laquelle on donne le feu vert
dépendamment de l'état de santé de la
personne et ensuite la vaccination en
soi qui va avoir lieu dans une autre
pièce là où le spoutnik et conservé à
moins 18 degrés la dîmière devra revenir
dans 21 jours pour sa deuxième piqûre
mais déjà derrière son masque se cache
un sourire
la prochaine et natalia une jeune
médecin elle au contraire dit avoir bien
réfléchi avant d'accepter de dax il elle
ne put s'empêcher de penser à tous les
patients qu'elle a vu mourir de la kfw
depuis printemps et elle ne veut plus
attendre
contrairement aux vaccins de paille ce
qui sera administré au royaume uni dès
cette semaine aussi le spoutnik v n'a
pas encore franchi la troisième et
dernière phase de la recherche avant
d'être offerts à la population
d'où la décision en russie jusqu'au 15
ou d'exclure les femmes enceintes les
enfants et les personnes âgées de plus
de 60 ans de cette première phase de la
vaccination
nos bombes selon chine no go toronto il
est docteur en dhr et yannick homme
assure que pour les autres les résultats
sont assez convaincants lancé la
vaccination de masse et la seule façon
de limiter les dégâts en russie mais il
faudra en convaincre plusieurs comme ces
deux femmes qui préfèrent attendre des
mois s'il le fait et pourquoi
on ne sait plus quoi penser est ce qu'il
est bon ou pas notre vaccin est ce qu'il
est trop tôt trop vite cette autre
sceptique dit qu'il ira quand les
dirigeants russes le front devant les
caméras d'ici là à tous ceux qui doutent
encore de l'efficacité du spoutnik
natalia la médecin vacciner et répond
spontanément drabo il n'en peut plus des
cercueils de l'isolément d'être à genoux
devant un virus et elle ne peut imaginer
pire que ce que la planète vit en ce
moment ici tamar altérait secoue
radio-canada moscou